✦シャキン✦
白いパンツをはくようになった
はじめしゃちょーです
（観客の笑い声）
フッｗ
バタン
やろう！やろやろ！
ピュンピュンピュン
ついに来たぞ～
動画のタイトル見れば分かると思うんですけども～
今日は！
浮きます！
いやこれは、本当にすごいと思う。マジで！
ついにホモサピエンスもここまで来たかと
僕はこの商品を見た瞬間思いました！
いやもうこれマジですごいからね！
はさみ～はさみは～はさみは～？
見つけた！
今日もいくぜ～ｗｗｗ
あっ！あ～
あっ！髪の毛染めました
参る！
ほっほっほっほっ！！　ズタッ！ズタッ！ズタッ！ズタッ！
コツン
～♪(´□｀。)♪～
アッ～～～～～
ズタッ！ズタッ！ズタッ！ズタッ！
ダ～クネ～ス
ガチで中身が心配
あ～やっちまった～泣
ガチで心配
大丈夫かな～
うん（泣）ちょっと心配
自己責任！壊れてたら俺のせいっす
いや大丈夫だと思うんですけども～
今回こちら！
「LEVI STAGE」
いやいや、ほんとすごいよ
空中に浮くんすよ
物が、ついに！！
は、ハ空中に浮くっ（くしゃみの様に）
いや、すごいでしょ
空中に浮くディスプレイスタンドが来ました
……汗やべえ
バリバリバリバリバリバリ
ズーーッ
いやいや、空中に浮くはやばいでしょ
うわ、マジじゃんこれ
もう、すぐ開けて、すぐ浮かせよ
テレン（シンバル）
アダプタ～
待って重かった、重かった
待て、開けた瞬間気づいた
うわ、これか～
壊れてないかだけ心配
うわっ出た
あっう～
こちら、本体のようです
ん～いかにも怪しいね
いかにも怪しい
好きだよ、こういうのｗ
説明書によると～
磁気コイルが内蔵されているみたいで
なるほどね～
ちょっとよく分かんない
とりあえずは、
保護シートって何？
保護シートなんてあったけ
これか！これが、これが保護シートらしいです
とりあえず、ufvhnc?
見たいよね！みんな！
みなさんが何を見たいかというと～
もう、浮くことだけだとおもうんですよ！
俺も見たいからさ～
もう、刺せばいいんだよね？
ドシュッ
あっ、光った
光ったよ！
ママ！光ったよ！
なんで？なんで？なんで？光ってんの？
ということは、こうか置き方は
こうですね、たぶん
ｗあうｗあｗうｗｗｗ
保護シートをセットして
磁石を～
これ～？
あっ分かったぞ　そういうことか
あれ？
これ待って、上じゃね
待って待ってｗｗ
あれ～
なんかね、上手いこと乗せれれば浮くみたいです
あかん　これマジでむずい
待って、ちょっと、ちゃんと手順を組んでやりましょう
設置します～
刺します～
光りました！
保護シートを置きます！
10cmの高さに磁石を配置してください
こんぐらいかな？　置きました
で、配置した場所から上向きの磁力を感じるところ
なるほど！磁力を感じるところまで、下げればいいのね
あっ感じた！
10cm離してゆっくり置いてって
LED消えるところまで落とすと
♪～
コツン
つかねえじゃねえか
キュキュｭキュー
えっ？
ｗｗｗ
なんか
エロいねｗ
光ったらOKなのね　分かった
まずは、場所をとる　高さ・・・
離していい？
今、4つ光ってるよね
うわぁ、待って、待って、待って、待って、待って
待て待て待て待て待ってて
待って来た来た来た来た～！
カモ、カモ、カモン
えっあっ待って浮いてる浮いてる
完全に浮いてるよ！ほら！
えっあっ待って浮いた浮いた浮いた
浮いたよー！
待って、浮いたってことは、
もう保護シートはずしていいんんだよね？
うわぁマジか～
うわぁ待って
うわぁマジだ
うわぁ待って本当に浮いてるよ～
種も仕掛けもございません
うわぁすげえな～
完全に浮いております
待ってこれ何でも乗せていいのかな？
だるまさんが浮いてるよ！
うわぁうわぁうわぁ
すごいすごいすごい
マジかマジかマジか
ちょっと待ってなんか浮かせよう！
俺のスマホは～？
あっ浮いちゃう～？
俺のスマホ浮いちゃうわけよ
うわぁこれマジか
本当にすごい
お前ちょっと重いかな～
コツン
あっｂｈｂｗくｄｓ？
だるまさんなら全然乗るんですけど～
お茶もばっちりです
（鼻をかむ音）
鼻をかんだティッシュも
オシャレに見えるよね
これたぶんね、フィギュアとか置くのが１番いいんですよね
いや、これね～
めちゃくちゃ良いよ～
めっちゃ良い買い物したと思ってる、今
めっちゃテンション上がってるから
すごいよ、本当に
（拍手の音）
拍手、これはすごい！
何だろう
物が浮いたりさぁ
空を飛ぶことって
すごい俺、夢があることだと思うんだよね
やっぱ見ててすごい感動する
amiiboとかもすごいかっこよく見えます
てか、もうこれやばいよ
完全次世代じゃん
だいすけの友達も
お～
こりゃ、いかついな～
これひょっとしたらHIKAKINさん・・・
浮くんじゃね
これHIKAKINさん浮くんじゃね！
親分！僕が親分を浮かせてあげます
親分！
～♪YouTubeテーマソング♪～
親分浮きましたよ！
おやぶ～ん
宙に浮くHIKAKINさんだ！
～♪ED♪～